[Applause]
a Victory Parade for Lionel Messi and
the national team in Buenos Aires on
Tuesday
17 he says he waited for hours just to
be able to see his Heroes
[Music]
it's such a special day and I dreamed to
see the players people question the
coach Leonel scalone but he managed to
build a team he gave us the copper
America the finalisima and now the World
Cup
is the center of Buenos Aires and this
is what it looks like there's people on
the top of the Obelisk there's people on
top of traffic light there's people on
the top of bus stops local media report
that over 3 million people took to the
streets in Buenos Aires to show their
support for Janelle Messi and the
national team
[Applause]
members did not want their Victory to be
politicized and that's why they did not
visit the presidential Palace they
wanted to celebrate with the people of
Argentina instead
because of the large crowds organizers
were forced to change the parade route
several times
people try to jump inside the bus
several people were injured
in the end the players had to switch
from the bus to five helicopters and
that's how that he managed to see the
display of affection across Buenos Aires
devotion for Messi is everywhere here
for years the football star struggled
with Argentina's national team and the
constant comparison with Diego Maradona
who helped Argentina win the World Cup
in 1986.
Juan Carlo Flamingo says Argentina needs
to ask for Messi's forgiveness
we failed messy all the people here we
underestimated him and now we are
waiting for him as if he is our God we
always spoke about Maradona it's
difficult to speak and it fills me with
emotions we disrespected him
Argentina has won its Third World Cup
the Football Association has already
stamped the third star on the blue and
white t-shirts that represents the
country's flag
football in Argentina is like a religion
and people here have found in Captain
Lionel Messi and his team the heroes
they have been waiting for a very long
time